quand j'entends le mot violence
policière moi je vais personnellement je
m'étouffe la police exerce une violence
certes mais une violence légitime c'est
vieux comme max weber après elle va le
faire de manière proportionnelle
une manière encadrée que quelques
personnes le fasse en dehors des règles
déontologiques de la sanction doit être
immédiate
mais il est normal que les policiers les
gendarmes soient armés interviennent pas
la force pour que justement la force
reste à la loi de la république et pas
la loi des bandes ou des communautés
donc par principe l'idée même de
violences policières ne me paraît être
totalement antinomique d'utiliser ces
deux mots voilà il peut y avoir des
dérives qu'on doit sanctionner et je
pense que les gouvernements les
sanctionne et s'il ne fait pas il faut
que la presse les syndicats les
parlementaires rappellent évidemment à
la hiérarchie policière remises de
l'intérieur ce qu'il doit faire et c'est
bien légitime mais je ne pense pas qu'il
faille comparer les violences voilà il y
en a qui sont légitimes
c'est l'exercice de la force par la
police et en a qui sont illégitimes
ces exercices de la force par des gens
qui ne sont pas policier ou d'un
gendarme